hey Joost ik Ben 28 en ik zoek 1 woning
wat gaat jij 21 voor mij doen
wij gaan in de eerste plaats
afremmen met 1 aantal studenten uit het buitenland
daar zijn er nu 120.000 van in Nederland
die bezetten allemaal studentenkamers
dat moet omlaag
daarnaast moeten we migratie überhaupt laten afnemen
naar Nederland
verbouwing in feite voor migranten
en daarnaast meer doorstroming
dus oudere mensen moeten verleiden om sneller naar hun
bejaardentehuis te gaan
die we kunnen herintroduceren
zodat er veel meer woningen vrijkomen
voor jongeren
dat zijn 1 paar voor onze maatregelen
kijk eens op onze website ja21 NL
en kom gewoon thuis bij het juiste antwoord